Guys, it is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
-Oh, yeah.
♪ -Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-We do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag,
and we ask you guys to respond
to that topic.
This is a great one.
This one might be my favorite
one we've ever done.
-Really?
-It's really, really
interesting, yeah.
So, if you have -- anyone --
call your friend right now
and say,
"Tune in to 'Jimmy Fallon.'
Something interesting is about
to happen."
-Oh, really?
[ Light laughter ]
-We sent out the hashtag,
#Iwastodayyearsold.
And I asked you to tweet out a
funny thing that blew your mind
recently.
-Nice.
-For me, it was that
croissant -- "croissant?"
-Yeah, "croissant."
-It's French for "crescent."
[ Laughter ]
-Crescent.
-I didn't -- But I didn't
realize that.
Do you -- If you --
'Cause I was making them
with the girls the other day --
the Pillsbury one, you know?
And just bend it in the shape
of a crescent.
-Oh...
-Croissant.
-That's it, so I was like,
"Whoa,
I was today years old
when I knew that."
So, within minutes, it was
a trending topic in the U.S.
So, thank you for playing along.
And now, I thought I would
share some of my favorite
"I was today years old"
tweets from you guys.
These are good.
[ Applause ]
Get -- no, get ready.
These are great.
Your minds are about to be
blown. Here we go.
This first one is from
@bdwaybrooke.
She said, "#iwastodayyearsold
when I realized the word 'bed'
is shaped like a bed."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh! Wild.
♪♪
-Right?
Is that phenomenal?
No, get ready.
There's -- this is --
-This is going to blow
your mind.
-This is the best thing --
This is the best one
we've ever done.
[ Laughter ]
I realize -- do you --
-I never realized that.
Ever.
-Bed is shaped like a bed.
All right, ready?
This one's from @benpack3521.
He says, "#iwastodayyearsold
when I heard Arby's is short for
RB, which stands for
roast beef.
I don't know if that's true, but
I read it on Facebook,
so it's probably accurate."
[ Laughter, applause ]
Sure.
-Yeah.
America's roast beef, nestle.
-Sounds right to me.
-Sure.
They've got the meat.
-Arby's.
-Yeah, and they've got the meat.
-Yeah.
-Roast beefs.
Wow. I love these.
I could do this all night long.
All right, this one is from
@Zayum -- oh, sorry, no.
Sorry, @Zaymun.
Oh. Sorry.
I thought it was "Zayum!"
-"Zayum!"
[ Laughter ]
-Zayum. Zayum, Zaniel.
-Zayum Zaniels."
-Zaymun.
-Oh.
He says, "Chinese food
containers unfold into plates."
-Oh, yeah!
[ Applause ]
-Uh-oh.
-Right, so, this is the
Chinese -- this --
you get it like this.
-Yeah.
-I did not --
I don't believe this.
I still kind of --
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoa!
Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding!
Mind, mind, mind, mind blown.
[ Applause ]
-That's cool.
-The snowflake plate.
-That's crazy.
I don't know if I would do it.
-Right, but you can.
[ Laughter ]
-If I could, I'd probably just
eat out of, like --
it's much easier
to eat it still folded.
-Sure, you can do that.
-I guess it's more
civilized like --
-Yeah, that's classy.
-This is classier.
-Yeah.
-But you have to take the food
out of it, maybe.
-Right.
-And then fold against
the creases.
-Right, so then, it doesn't
fall in your lap.
-Yeah, but this is --
look at that.
It's a gorgeous paper plate.
-Right!
"Spoing!"
-Fun, yeah. Love it.
Anyways, today years old.
This one's from @Charleyck14.
They say, "#iwastodayyearsold
when I noticed the major league
baseball logo looks like a
really happy bird playing
baseball."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Cawing ]
[ Cymbal crash ]
[ Laughter and applause
continues ]
Isn't that cool?
-I never noticed that.
-Yeah, we got -- all right,
we got four more.
These are all good.
Oh, this one's really
interesting.
This one's from @cynthialallan.
She says, "#iwastodayyearsold
when I learned most men
shower facing the shower head.
Women face the opposite wall.
And neither knows
this of the other."
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh.
-Do you face --
-Is that true?
-Do you face the shower?
You face away?
-Wow.
I face the shower. Of course!
-I face the shower.
-Head on.
Let's go, bud.
-Come on, Zayum.
-Come on. Bring it.
-Yeah, bring it.
-Bring it.
[ Laughter ]
Isn't that wild?
[ Applause ]
So cool.
This is from @triplec50.
They say, "#iwastodayyearsold
when I learned that if you
pinch your nose tightly,
it makes it difficult to hum."
[ Laughter ]
[ Attempting to hum ]
-It does.
-Can't breathe, I guess.
[ Laughter ]
-If you close your mouth --
-People would probably die
trying that.
-If you close your
mouth, you can't sing.
-Yeah, I guess.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't know that.
[ Applause ]
-"Zayum!"
Oh, is this the last one?
-This is the last one here.
This one is from
@timfanchercomic.
He said, "#iwastodayyearsold
when I learned that Jimmy Fallon
was once a Calvin Klein model."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoa!
Oh, snap.
-"Zayum."
There you have it.
Those are the
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more, go to
tonightshow.com/hashtags.